ma'am
Hi how are you
you all
right bro who served her a Georgia
County Commissioner is out of a job
after being found passed out outside a
bar and later hurling insults at Medics
who were tending to her care get out my
face I don't give a get him out my face
you better get out my face him you got
to get him out my face ma'am you're
about to go to jail I don't give a f get
him out my face there you do you get him
out my
face the incident happened on September
29th in Clayton County Georgia when
police found a woman lying on the ground
outside a local sports bar when the
officers check on her she's not able to
say a word so they lift her up on a
bench nearby to sit her upright
Hi how are
you you all
right
who served her we got we got an ANS
[Music]
coming County Commission police are able
to identify the woman as Clayton County
Board of Commissioners Vice chair ficia
Franklin after calling in to report the
incident the officers are pulled to the
side by a witness to try to get a better
understanding of what
happened I don't know yeah just let just
let check her out for for on our C and
then can just get her out y'all can take
her take we we want to make sure she
does have like some kind of
head city was laying
down behind I guess she rolled off we
want to make sure she didn't hit her
hand that's so yous responding yeah will
come and check her out right quick make
sure she at least you
no I didn't see I didn't see well she
got out I saw a stagger yeah she was
staggered out here so I asked her I
didn't know who she was I asked her I
said hey are you driving she said no she
had a ride so okay yeah she said she had
a
ride
okay
okay I prefer just get her home we get
her home safe as long as
she's long as she's not any trauma
trauma is out of my hand yeah but out of
that i' rather no no y y'all are good I
mean no it's you understand what I'm
saying yeah I get what you saying but I
mean y'all y'all can take her home we
just want to make because she fell off
the bench we want to make sure she
didn't have something wrong with she her
head or something like that let see if I
can get her shortly after EMS arrives
and police quickly inform them of what's
going on so apparently she fell off the
bench he found her on the ground over
here make sure
she doing all right we got one that fell
on Off the Bench uh uh we don't know if
she hit her head or not uh we just they
just want to check out they going to
they want to just transport her home but
we always want to make sure that she's
good to
go EMS then try to speak to Franklin but
she's barely able to make a cohesive
sentence what's your name sir my
name you don't know I already let him
know that you going take her yeah we got
to we got to we we just want to check
her out and see make sure she's
good you answer my questions I need to
take you to the hospital
be careful right there Sheed all of
herself okay
so you
[Applause]
okay how are you going to get that
boy fig no can't get
that that's
my I tell let's go my still
bed would you give her a hand you want
to take her now I'll put in the back of
my truck and take a look at
her is this your bag
sit what color is your
purse
who are you here
with you came by yourself you sure as
hell ain't going to drive home not like
this so we need to get you somewhere
besides right
here got
you what some water there no no water no
water until I figure out what's going on
with
it
is this her person and belonging here
yes okay and she's here by
herself huh me something to
drink something in your drink or a drink
that
you susceptible to like I can't drink
tequila and I got one additional one she
said right now is she refusing the
MS there somebody I have not I have not
evaluated her okay I don't want to get
it I'm not trying to get it away I
apolog I stand back so we're going to go
to the back of my truck okay iiz and do
a little bit more talking I apologize
she's saying that somebody gave her
something in a
drink I don't know what's going on still
unable to move on her own EMS places
Franklin on on to the gurnie for
evaluation come on up here sweetie put
your legs under you put your
leg me something to drink I
your that looks like my ink pan is it
your I got it is my ink
pan all right strap her to go to the
truck sit up for
me much in the head correct what that be
I don't
know I don't know
what they gave
me know
they I don't know what they gave me are
you okay no I'm not I don't know what
they
gave right here we got it right here
okay they're going to they're going to
they're not taking her yet they're just
going to put her in the back evaluat her
okay my mom is her emergency contact and
she's on the way my mom called me here
I'm just trying to find out where you're
at around right now okay okay I just in
another officer's body cam Franklin can
be heard screaming and crying at the top
of her lungs as they move her to the
ambulance I don't know what they gave
me love
me they love me here don't leave me
don't leave me don't leave me don't
leave me don't leave me don't leave me
don't leave me don't leave me I
was don't leave me don't leave me don't
leave me don't leave
me
sh can I get
anotherr Franklin's friend then arrives
on scene Franklin still visibly upset
repeats to her friend that she believed
she was
drugged I don't know what happened I
came here and I enjoed the music and I
got left
here
[Music]
[Applause]
he okay I'm right here I'm right here
I'm not going anywhere what happened
she's spitting up she's throwing up
after Franklin projectile vomits all
over herself back on the other officer's
body cam the EMT can be heard quickly
noticing the smell of alcohol coming
from the county official that's whiskey
you drink
bur I don't know what what do you been
drinking tonight any Burg I don't know I
just want patty patty come to me Patty
Patty I can't
do
Kay pleas help me please help
me please help me please help me while
emergency officials tend to Franklin her
friend Patty tells officers what she
believes is the reason for Franklin's
questionable night like say the way it
smells it's it's some type of like
whiskey or bourbon with the medication
the
medication probably I saw when it came
up it wasn't anything other than fluid
it wasn't fluid yeah there there was
some specs of something in there
I the the only reason we called a was is
because she did Roll Off the Bench no
she needs to be looked at she called me
and her phone went down I couldn't get
her back Kayla found out where she was
and we both came here I live right off
spying so yeah no you're good yeah but
we just because she rolled off oh no I
get you I understand we want make sure
than you I appreciate that no literally
last Friday I spent all day in the
emergency room with her with she
couldn't breathe cuz she had bronchitis
acute bronchitis and see that that that
color yeah says I know she's been on
medication for two weeks so she probably
shouldn't have been out tonight but I'm
sure she had Cabin Fever is what it was
she had Cabin Fever just wanted to
listen to some music while in the
ambulance Franklin still is unable to
calm down frequently screaming for her
friend to be by her side but in a
shocking turn Franklin turns on the
people helping with her care I'm going
have to take for public tr get about
this
truck he's get about this truck for me P
please Patty come to me Patty get him
out this truck I can't do it get get him
out of my truck get him the out of this
truck get him the out get him of his
truck they can try Miss call
you
get all right she's not cooperating with
him I know I can see it you they don't
mind if you try talking to her okay
but we're not going to lock her up or
anything like that no cuz it didn't
start till after we picked her up in her
like that
so she needs to be checked out okay and
they can't do that while she was
fighting okay I got you so um try uh
let's go over this door here
[Applause]
K we going to get her to come this
side
[Applause]
get him
get
get Felicia look at me look at
me Felicia got to check you out baby
listen to
me no no no no no they're they're
they're trying to help don't hit them
they're
trying help
me listen to me listen to me I
can't listen to you I can't listen to
you I Cana I take to to the hospital and
restrain you if you don't why you take
me to if you take me you take
meel Felicia l
listen to me listen to me listen to me
listen to
me listen to me sh you're okay you're
okay no I'm not yeah you are you're okay
no I'm not look at me no I'm not look at
me in your look at me look at me no
no this is a nightmare get him out this
Tru get him this don't do this
Franklin's friend continues to try to
calm her down but still strapped onto
the gurnie Franklin remains unruly
before going into complete hysterics
he's gone he's gone he's
gone you need to stop Felicia you're
going to make it worse than what it
needs to be Fela you
mother no she's not he's not making it
worse we're all trying to help no you're
not no you're not honey you fell down
you fell down we want to make sure that
you're not no you're not no you're not
we got to make sure you're okay no
you're not no you're
not can't do
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Franklin refuses to let the
remaining EMT take her blood pressure
minutes go by and no one is able to calm
her down as more of Franklin's loved
ones arrive on scene it's evident the
county leader will not be able to go
home right away and she needs to be
checked out in a hospital she just threw
up again I she oh she threw up again
what he said is she's got to sign a
release and she's got to walk to a car
she can't do either one of those right
now so I think she has to go to the
hospital can't take her not unless she
can sign a release and walk to the car
is what he told the concern is that she
she
she rolled off and she may have hit her
head that may be the cause of the
vomiting too it could be a lot of
factors but cuz she was on the ground
out here what when I got here y'all just
put her on yeah we were picking her up
so concussions you know if if you hit it
just right it causes vomiting and
disorientation she hit her head just
right so that that's my concern that's
why we called the Ang I think we have to
have her checked out I don't want to
take her home and leave her there by
herself cuz it I don't want to risk it I
have to and they she won't let them
touch her I said let's at least check
your blood pressure she's like no she
won't even let them touch her um if they
will allow someone to ride with her
would somebody be willing to ride with
her okay moments later back on the
ambulance an EMT can be heard giving a
Stern and final warning to Franklin the
abuse needs to end you will sit still
and you will shut up at this point in
time I've had it I've had it we're at
zero right now I tried every Avenue to
help you but you are not cooperating
with me you're going to sit here and
you're going to be quiet and we're going
to take you to the hospital am I clear
am I clear Patt get my I don't care who
Patty is you are my
patient Mosley get him out yes ma'am my
last name is Mosley and I work for the
city of
Merl get him out my face get out my face
despite that warning as the EMT straps
down Franklin to the gurnie the violent
insults continue call Katie get him out
my face so the choice is do you want to
go to the hospital or you want to go to
jail you get him out my face you did not
handle this we're going to the hospital
going to the hospital be quiet cuz
either way you'll have to go to the
hospital cuz the jail won't take you
this drunk I'm not that drunk you can
take me to the hospital get him out my
face get him out my face be out of your
face in a minute get him on my face
making you safe get him on my face
making you sa get him on my face you
call my father you call anybody but get
him on my face all right we got you get
him out my
face get him out my face don't you move
this truck until you get him out my face
yeah shortly after EMTs are finally able
to transport Franklin to a local
hospital when the officer arrives
Franklin can be heard Still shouting now
begging and tear fearfully pleading for
her mother to be called for several
minutes don't leave me here please don't
leave
[Music]
me she was a
good I
[Music]
I just
my lay back I don't want to be at
Southern Regional I just want my mom
okay lay back for me lay back no yes no
yes I'm not going to be at Southern
Regional these are Crooks I want my mom
okay my mom gave up license medical
profession I just want my lay back m m
Warner you don't understand you're right
I don't I do don't understand I just
want
my I can only imagine back for us back F
get my
I want my mommy I want my mom got she
gave my life to this profession I want
my mommy I want my
mommy I want my
momy I want my bom can you bring my bom
back no ma I can't I don't have that
ability I can do a lot of things but
that ain't one of them please please
please that's not one of the things I
can do man please
please let no can you please you got let
me go man okay I can't bring her back
please I wish I could I took camera
until she passed away please no you
don't understand please I I took care of
her until she left this world I promise
can you bring her back please please
bring please bring her back
[Music]
please
pleas Hospital staff the emergency crew
and the officer are able to place
Franklin on the hospital bed and that's
when the body cam video ends following
the incident and now sober Franklin was
interviewed by police where she gave her
own account of what she remembered tell
me why are you here and what's going on
I know a little bit about it but not a
lot well basically I've have been um
dealing with bronchitis for like two
weeks okay at been in um started to feel
better I had to make a a run I was
telling beautifully and so I thought
I've missed music for a minute I've been
singing professionally all my life okay
and so I normally don't go anywhere by
myself per say but if I go to a place
and I see music and I see somebody I
know then I will feel comfortable okay
and that's what I did in fact I was um
went to the kmt first to see if they had
something there was nothing there and
then I um where's that at that was just
right off of
um
Mercedes um and I didn't have anything
there nothing at all I went in they had
a private event so I just had the valy
bring my car back around long as I was
there going on my car okay so then I was
like wow I've been in the whole time I
really would love to hear some music I
heard in a minute so then I remembered
there was a place by South Lake and as I
drove by I could hear the music so then
I thought you know I'll go in and see if
I know anybody knew one of the drummers
that was playing and I stayed up front
the whole time right and was fine the
whole time in fact I showed him my
countenance but at some point what was
the name of the drummer you know um it
was like Landy but they didn't that it
was it was a band that I knew okay it
was at thealist she took care of me she
stayed after and helped they called
another friend that knew me from the
music industry okay the biggest thing is
that um after being there and heing the
once they packed up is when I
noticed something was going on I wasn't
quite sure then after sitting there for
a minute I thought you know what I need
to go ahead and leave normally I would
leave right after the van but then when
I got up to walk out the door literally
and I have four kids now it's like my
body just went out it was not a head
swimming it was not anything like that
it was like my body stopped
functioning that's how it felt when they
got me on the G and inside that's when
they said somebody woke me up and I
became very combative correct according
to my doctor who was on the line with
Kayla she she knows my doctor and all of
that um my doctor said that it sounded
as if I had superhuman strength Patty
said the same thing and they said I was
very very combative and I kept throwing
up profusely right and that's all I
remember and I remember my dad bringing
me home
and um I didn't I just wanted to rest
and sleep shortly after officers
informed Franklin she had way more to
drink than she originally thought how
many drinks did you had again you think
I had wine and then that that was it and
I didn't finish
it and I didn't have anything else in my
mind other than when I went to the
doctor they gave me um for bronchitis
what is it like like an inhaler or
something yeah the inhaler and that was
it I think I would have gone out I've
been home for two weeks because I was
taking the meds and that what you what
are you taking prone yes
okay
um I just want to be very blunt with you
you going to be blunt you had five
drinks I didn't drink five drinks I
don't video drink all counted all five
of them just want to let you know that I
had five drinks yes
ma'am yes I don't remember having five
drinks yeah I mean I don't remember that
and then they gave me your receipt as
well and it shows all the drinks on here
as well yeah three home runs they in
they have pink no this I didn't even
order food other people have this I
didn't drink that right well they put
somebody else's on my tab that is not
what I I didn't even eat that that's
what he said he said he never saw you
with food and that's what I asked him
okay how' that no I did not so you're
saying that you saw the camera footage
her drinking five drinks yes I had and
he and he he got a he made a timeline
let me see and all of it I did not have
five drinks
Marty not that I know of and I didn't
even order food he put everybody on my
bill you saw them serve me five drinks
counted them you saw them put five
drinks on my
table there were and if you saw the
drink the band was up there singing they
trying to say I saw you sitting with a
vanand no you're going to they're going
to make those my drinks we going we
going to find out hold on this is
upsetting this is a set up we saw her
order them but not consume them is what
I'm not trying to figure out and he put
them on my bill I've I've seen her
consuming a couple drinks okay hav it
got the total count okay but from what I
count she had the wine to go in the
second drink she had was the home run
which has got the Hennessy in it with
the right he she said she think about a
third of that one and took that one back
and ordered the new one like you said at
the bar and wasn't a
third or the third one the bartender
said that she told you to get with your
server uh there's video of him them
bringing you the third drink um and I've
seen the video of after the vanand left
you're sitting there at the table on
your phone
you picked a coron up by accident I'm
assuming what put that up picked a look
like a grown at me or whatever it was a
beer bottle that's when I started
feeling funny after the band left is
what I told you when I first watch
walked in that's when it got fuzzy
because I don't remember Franklin
maintains someone had to have put
something inside her drink that caused
her reaction however investigators said
they could not find any evidence of
tampering with her drink weeks after the
incident County officials voted to
remove Franklin from her role as
commission's Vice chairwoman Franklin
later announced she's filing a lawsuit
to sue Clayton County for wrongful
termination after booting her from her
position reporting for long crime
Network I'm Elizabeth Milner